aquí
[Música]
vivimos una revolución de los datos
estamos conectados las 24 horas del día
a través de nuestros dispositivos
móviles y sensores corporales le
preguntamos a google aquello que no nos
animaríamos ni siquiera preguntarle a
nuestro psicólogo registramos nuestro
periodo en aplicaciones móviles y hasta
somos capaces de enviar nuestra saliva
por correo para que una empresa en eeuu
los secuencia el adn y lo suba a la nube
justamente hace dos meses un artículo en
el new york times dio a conocer que el
adn del 50% de la población de eeuu ya
está en la nube y esto no es porque uno
de cada dos personas en ese país
pusieron su saliva en un sobre y lo
enviaron para que empresas como tú en
instruyen me de secuencia al adn y lo
suba a la nube sino porque cada vez que
compartes tu información genética está
revelando también la de tu familia
y esto va a más bajo el paradigma de la
ciudad inteligente veremos como todo
nuestro entorno comienza a llenarse de
dispositivos de sensores
las calles los coches las farolas las
cámaras de vigilancia a nuestros propios
cuerpos irán produciendo un flujo
incesante de datos
un estudio que se publicó en force dijo
que para el año 2025 ya habrá más de 80
mil millones de sensores conectados en
el mundo es decir los sensores que
tenemos hoy multiplicados por cuatro
el poder de los datos es fascinante con
los datos correctos podríamos gestionar
mejor los servicios nuestros de cada día
desde el tráfico de los coches hasta la
seguridad la salud e incluso la
educación o la contaminación que generan
las ciudades
en el año 2013 un grupo de
investigadores de microsoft research
siguió los mensajes que un grupo de
mujeres embarazadas compartía en twitter
y creó un algoritmo que le permitió
identificar cuáles de ellas iban a tener
depresión postparto
en ese mismo año un grupo de
investigadores en washington
juntó los datos de las búsquedas en
google de recetas altas en sal la geo
localizó y pude identificar qué
hospitales recibirían mayores afectados
por problemas cardiovasculares ese fin
de semana
cuando se combinan con las capacidades
de la inteligencia artificial el poder
de los datos es aún mayor ya en el año
2018 tenemos proyectos como inr aid que
permiten a los médicos hacer la
detección temprana de tumores planificar
lo que la operación como si se tratara
de un mapa google maps
y prescribir tratamientos específicos
para cada paciente potente no
pero
cada invención genera su propio
accidente no había naufragios antes de
que existieran los barcos así como
tampoco hubiéramos vivido el escándalo
de que enbridge a analítica si no
hubiera sido porque antes le contamos
todo sobre nosotros mismos a facebook
cada vez que utilizamos internet
dispositivos conectados
estamos dejando una huella de datos
a través de los datos de uso de nuestro
móvil en nuestros ordenadores es posible
saber con quién hablas a qué hora le
hablas donde está esa persona a la que
le hablas dónde vives y dónde trabajas
incluso podríamos saber con los
metadatos de tu móvil en qué te
trasladas desde tu casa hasta tu trabajo
muchas veces la gente cree que esto no
le afecta porque no tiene nada que
ocultar
amazon utiliza nuestros patrones de
búsqueda para comparar esos datos con
los de otros usuarios y decidir qué
precio cobrarte por un producto con tus
datos de salud y el uso que haces de tu
móvil y tus redes sociales una empresa
aseguradora podría saber antes que tú
que vas a tener tal o cual enfermedad y
decidir cobrarte más curiosamente o
incluso dejarte sin cobertura o tu banco
puede utilizar los datos de uso de tu
móvil para adjudicarse a ti un nivel de
riesgo y sobre la base de ese nivel de
riesgo decidir si te va a dar un crédito
o no
lo veis si tienes suficientes datos
sobre algo tienes la cosa en si tienes
la cosa en sí si tienes suficientes
datos sobre una persona acaso puedes
controlar a esa persona
en el ámbito de la ciudad las
administraciones públicas no pueden
poner a los ciudadanos a merced de
gobiernos y empresas cuyos fines
desconocemos si lo hacen
nuestras ciudades podrían convertirse en
centros comerciales o lo que es peor aún
en cárceles hay cientos de estudios que
demuestran que cuando no sabemos
vigilados cambiamos nuestro
comportamiento que la vigilancia atenta
contra nuestra libertad y nuestra
autonomía
por eso richard sennett decía en esa
ciudad inteligente romeo y julieta nunca
podrían haberse enamorado
en el pasado foro de davos angela merkel
dijo los datos son la materia prima del
siglo 21 la cuestión de quién es dueño
de los datos va a definir si la
democracia el modelo social
participativo y la prosperidad económica
pueden ser compatibles
ante esta situación
nos enfrentamos a la pregunta qué
ciudades queremos tener pero más
importante aún que sociedad
queremos ser
cuando los ciudadanos estamos en poder
de nuestros datos estamos capacitados
para tomar mejores decisiones a nivel
individual y a nivel colectivo
mi propia experiencia me ha demostrado
que cuando los ciudadanos son capaces de
producir y gobernar sus datos sus
agendas avanzan así lo hicimos en
barcelona donde trabajamos con una
comunidad en el barrio de gràcia que
hacía 20 años estaba afectada por la
contaminación acústica utilizamos
sensores para medir el ruido y con esos
datos pudimos demostrar que su salud
estaba en juego y con esos datos
logramos que el ayuntamiento trabajará
para resolver el tema también lo hicimos
así en prístina la capital de kosovo
donde con los ciudadanos utilizamos
sensores de calidad del aire y pudimos
ver que los datos que publicaba la
administración pública no eran del todo
veraces y que la situación de la
contaminación estaba afectando la vida
misma de las personas y de nuevo gracias
a esos datos y esa participación
ciudadana logramos promover legislación
para que la cuestión se remedie y hay
otros motivos para alegrarnos
y la unión europea en 2018 finalmente
puso en vigor el plan general de
protección de datos
que reconoce que los ciudadanos somos
dueños de nuestros datos y tenemos el
poder de gobernar los podemos incluso
aportar los de una plataforma digital a
otras barcelona ha lanzado un plan de
soberanía digital que busca empoderar a
los ciudadanos en esa misma dirección
imaginen esto
si poniendo en común todo nuestro
conocimiento los ciudadanos hemos creado
la wikipedia la enciclopedia más grande
del mundo que resuelve más de 500
millones de consultas de conocimiento
cada mes de manera gratuita que otras
maravillas seríamos capaces de lograr si
pudiéramos producir y controlar nuestros
datos la ciudad inteligente hoy es la
que articula las infraestructuras
técnicas y legales para que los
ciudadanos tomemos el control de
nuestros datos podamos utilizarlos sobre
la base de los criterios que creemos van
a generar un beneficio personal pero
también un beneficio colectivo
las administraciones públicas para que
esto sea posible también podrían
comenzar a crear los cursos de
capacitación necesarios para que los
ciudadanos podamos sacar el mejor
provecho de estas tecnologías y qué
podemos hacer los ciudadanos podemos ver
que el poder está en nuestras manos y
cada vez más las legislaciones nos dan
la razón
nuestros datos agregados tienen
muchísimo más valor por eso vemos el
surgimiento de cooperativas de datos
donde los ciudadanos se agrupan y logran
agregar sus datos para preservar la
privacidad y establecer las condiciones
bajo las cuales estos datos pueden ser
usados
hace 100 años córdoba en su mejor
versión la córdoba rebelde dio un paso
fundamental en la democratización de la
educación y el conocimiento
esa revolución educativa
inspiró y benefició a millones en toda
la región democratizó el acceso al
conocimiento
hoy nos invitó a volver a poner a
córdoba en el mapa a convertirla en
líder de un nuevo movimiento de ciudades
inteligentes que utilizan el poder de
los datos y el poder de las nuevas
tecnologías y las capacidades ciudadanas
para generar un bien común para
redistribuir esta materia prima del
siglo 21 que son los datos yo sé que me
van a decir que esto es muy difícil y
esto no es fácil porque implica
enfrentarnos a enormes poderes
económicos y políticos y porque implica
sobre todo cambiar la forma de hacer las
cosas pero como dijo mandela
parece imposible hasta que se hace
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah